this is what loss looks like
a new beach resort used to stand here
now
nothing
images from inside tonga are a catalogue
of disaster rubble replaces homes
streets are choked with volcanic ash
which poisons the air
first we thought it was rain but there
were bits
and pieces of rocks
and then after the rocks came down then
we had the dust
and we could not see
while we're driving
marion has been documenting the damage
the phone networks are mainly down she's
one of the few who've managed to call
out we need drinking clean drinking
water our national water supplies is not
safe enough for us to drink
delivering aid fast is now the focus
ships laden with clean water tents and
food are being sent by australia and new
zealand
eighty percent of tongans have been
affected by the volcano and tsunami
whole villages destroyed more than
eighty thousand people are in need we're
talking about complete devastation in
terms of loss of infrastructure loss of
homes there's some of these islands
um every single home has been lost on
one of the islands there's only two
houses standing there all the
infrastructure has been washed away
widespread damage and covered fears mean
getting supplies in and news out is
painfully slow
[Applause]
stranded by the pandemic in the u.s
netta was on the phone to her kids in
tonga when the waves hit
for three days she didn't know if they
were alive it's a huge
a disaster in tonga it's life of death
matters so
without hearing them um
i was just lost the last few days i
heard the noise and the eruption
happening and i was the one who was
telling them they should move to a
higher ground
and they did
as further surveillance flights are
readied communication is slowly
improving
the first international aid is due to
arrive on friday
almost a week after this disaster struck
siobhan robbins sky news